1998 2000 16 18 ans 18 ans que le projet
d'enfouissement de la nationale 10
attrapés dans les cartons un enjeu
majeur pour la mairie et qui semble
enfin avancer les élus municipaux ont
validé hier mercredi 16 novembre le
protocole financier entre les différents
partis est à régions départements
agglomérations et communes on a fait un
conseil municipal exceptionnel de façon
à être prêt pour le les jours qui
viennent ou normalement avec l'état le
conseil régional le conseil
départemental la communauté
d'agglomération et la ville
on doit signer le contrat de financement
convient de 2 votée à l'unanimité moins
une voix à ce conseil municipal
selon le pacte financier voté hier le
projet du recouvrement partiel de la n
10 devrait coûter 95,1 millions d'euros
dont 42 à la charge de l'état très et
demi pour l'agglomération et 2 pour la
commune de trappes une répartition voté
par l'opposition de droite
là pour l'instant il n'y a pas de débat
particulier sur sur ce point là il
pourrait y en avoir plus tard à propos
du projet proprement dit qui nous pose
quelques questions en termes de
désengorgement réel de la ville en
moyenne 80 mille véhicules passent tous
les jours sur la nationale 10 au niveau
de trappes il y a donc urgence pour les
habitants même si le projet présenté
hier ne fait pas l'unanimité 81 90 mille
voitures par jour enfin voitures et
camions et le bruit la pollution et on
peut pas on peut pas laisser une ville
comme ça on est d'avancer en visionner
ce trafic on est tous d'accord qui a un
problème mais la solution que nous
propose elle ne nous satisfait pas une
enquête publique est organisée jusqu'au
17 décembre en mairie de trappes les
travaux devraient débuter en 2018 pour
une mise en service espérée en 2021 soit
23 ans après le lancement du projet